this is one of the most frustrating things I've ever seen on this app
this video I mean
this is just racism or bigotry of low expectations to the UMP degree
this is the like this year
legitimizing the actions of a terrorist organization and it's
it's vile it's vile
so you're saying that because Palestinians grew up in the intephadas
which they started by the way
and saw things
bad things happen in their countries
which were brought on by the actions of their relatives
or the people in their country
that they now have free rein
or Israeli should just accept well
well put our hands up
we we deserve this
Israeli should just accept them breaking through the border of the country
and graping and mass murdering Israelis
who have nothing to do with the government
that's what you're saying
so if you perceive your grandparents as being wronged by my grandparents
when there's no facts
evidence proof anything
you can just come brutally grape me
you experience something bad in your life
so that means that violence against me is totally justified
you can do that
this is obviously wrong
you can't obviously do that
and while you can have empathy
for the positions that the Palestinians have been put in
you can absolutely never justify the ways that they go about expressing this um
resistance to their oppressors
the standard western thinking for years
was that if you have a country with a more powerful military
it will mean that other people will not go attack that country
because they know
common sense that if they attack one country with a stronger military
that that country will come back and strike them 10 times harder
now what's the difference between Israel and Gaza or Hamas
the difference is that Israel is fighting a genocidal death cult
a jihadist death cult
with a death wish they want
they think if they can go kill Israelis
that's a great thing
and if they die while trying to kill Israelis
that's also a great thing
and a lot of them don't feel this way
but a lot of them also do
the last poll I saw was that 73% of people in Gaza
post October 7th support what Hamas did
why do they support this
because they are raised to
in their schools hate Jews
they're taught the most vile
anti Semitic things I've ever
I've ever seen
just Google Palestinian math textbook
Google Palestinian cartoons
or Gaza cartoons
just Google that
and furthermore
you know a lot of Israelis grew up inside
their parents
get hurt or killed by Palestinians
and you know what
I haven't heard of a single Israeli in the last 20 years
that went into the West Bank or Gaza in a coordinated effort
in tried to kill as many Palestinians as possible
I know that's happened
but I think it's happened a couple times in the history of this conflict
rather than every two years
I understand you wanna sound
like super empathetic and all of this stuff
but it's horseshoe theory
you went from being super empathetic to one side
to justifying the brutal grape and murder of another side
I don't know how we got to this point
in America like
three years ago
if someone was accused of using the word boofing
it meant that they
obviously must be a serial rapist and
like deviant
and now we have video evidence of Hamas mass griping women
in Israel on October 7th
and it's like oh it's
it's no big deal
we can have like a
a common morality here
we can say like Kay
not cool to murder anyone
not cool to do that
and we can also have an understanding of that if
if Hamas if these Palestinian terror groups
continue to fund and launch these terrorist attacks on Israelis that it
they will obvious
obviously be met with Israeli like
IDF responses
like obviously
and if your reply is that
that response is
what's the problem
and not the fact that the Palestinians did what they did in the first place
as the problem
then you are a very big problem
dude oh my god